life becomes easier when you delete the
unnecessary people from
[Music]
it life doesn't always give Second
Chances take the first
[Music]
one live to be happy and be happy to be
alive the only life worth living is the
one you're passionate
[Music]
about be grateful for what you have and
your life will reward you with
more life is a challenge meet
[Music]
it to live a creative life we must lose
our fear of being
wrong what we do in life echoes in
eternity
the hard part is not making a decision
it's living with
[Music]
it life is like photography you use the
negatives to
develop life is a great story that
someone ruined with the
[Music]
truth life is full of open doors but
some need to be
shut the drama of life begins with a
whale and ends with a
sigh life is 10% what happens to you and
90% how you respond to
it life is what you make
it in the end it's not the years in your
life life that count it's the life in
your
[Music]
years your time is limited don't waste
it living someone else's
life you get out of life what you have
the courage to ask
[Music]
for God gave us the gift of life it is
up to us to give ourselves the gift of
living
well
in three words I can sum up everything
I've learned about life it goes
on to live is the rarest thing in the
world most people simply
exist you can never plan the future by
living in the
past we make a living by what we get we
make a life by what we
give all life is an experiment the more
experiments you make the
better you only live once but if you do
it right once is
enough life ought to be a struggle of
Desire toward Adventures whose nobility
will fertilize the
soul
[Music]
the greatest mistake you can make in
life is to be continually fearing you
will make a
mistake life is not a problem to be
solved it is a reality to be
experienced you can't live your life for
other people you've got to do what's
right for you even if it hurts some
people you
love
I've come to believe that all my past
failure and frustration were actually
laying the foundation for the
understandings that have created the new
level of living I now
enjoy life's wisdom can often miss us
because life moves so fast that we have
to practice standing
still life is inherently risky there is
only one big risk you should avoid at
all costs the risk of doing
nothing only a life lived for others is
a life
worthwhile the greatest day in your life
and mine is when we take total
responsibility for our attitude that's
the day we truly grow
[Music]
up everyone in life is going to hurt you
you just have to figure out which people
are worth the
pain no one ever finds life worth living
one has to make it worth
[Music]
living accept responsibility for your
life know that it is you who will get
you where you want to go no one
[Music]
else an unexamined life is not worth
living life is much more fun if you live
it in the spirit of play and
collaboration working with instead of
against
others life is a succession of lessons
that must be lived to be
understood things change friends leave
life doesn't stop for anybody
live life to the fullest and focus on
the
[Music]
positive I've failed over and over and
over again in my life that is why I
succeed life is a question how we live
it is the
answer today is life the only life you
are sure of Mak the most of
today life takes on meaning when you
become motivated set goals and charge
after them in an Unstoppable
manner life is not a matter of holding
good cards but sometimes playing a poor
hand
well singleness of purpose is one of the
chief Essentials for success in life no
matter or what one's aim may
[Music]
be each of us experiences defeats in
life we can transform defeat into
Victory if we learn from life's
failures there are three constants in
life change choice and
principles I think of Life as a good
book the further you get into it the
more it begins to make
sense there's no life as complete as the
life that is lived by
choice life is not about how fast you
run or how high you climb but how well
you
bounce don't search for the meaning of
life simply be present for the people
you love
each life is made up of mistakes and
learning waiting and growing practicing
patience and being
persistent life is simple but we insist
on making it
complicated life isn't complicated if
you don't lose your concentration on
your true
vision
wake up to realities real life is all
about real
things life is like a roller coaster you
will have your ups and downs you just
need to get over
it life is a lively process of
[Music]
becoming in order to write about life
you must first live it
the whole secret of a successful life is
to find out what is one's Destiny to do
and then to do
it life is a flower of which love is the
honey life is a mountain your goal is to
find your path not to reach the
[Music]
top do not not take life too seriously
you will never get out of it
alive life is like a box of chocolates
you never know what you're going to
get believe that life is worth living
and your belief will make it
so which way you choose to see your life
in the future depends on your attitude
today
each person must live their life as a
model for
[Music]
others life often teaches us through our
wrong turns and missed
[Music]
opportunities life is under no
obligation to give us what we
[Music]
expect live as if you were to Die
Tomorrow learn as if you were to live
[Music]
forever if you want to live a happy life
tie it to a goal not to people or
[Music]
objects the happiness of your life
depends upon the quality of your
thoughts
you will face many defeats in your life
but never let yourself be
defeated the two most important days in
your life are the day you were born and
the day you find out
why life is short break the rules
forgive quickly kiss slowly love truly
laugh
uncontrollably and never regret anything
that makes you
[Music]
smile thank you for watching which quote
did you like best let us know in the
comments